Dracarys
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my house
of the Dragon Daenerys Targaryen video there are
several references in Easter eggs for her during
episode 1 and throughout the entire series and
they really want to connect rhaenyra to her
because there are a lot of things about the two
of them that are very similar things that they
do and just things about them in general along
with the fact that they just look very similar
like Millie Alcock the actress who plays Young
rhaenyra on the show looks like she could also
be Amelia Clark's great-great-great-grandmother
many times removed so I'll explain all the Easter
eggs and foreshadowing connection between the two
of them across the many generations of their
family if you're new to the channel I'll be
doing videos for all the episodes just like I did
for the main Series Game of Thrones be sure to
subscribe to get them all we're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post your favorite
Daenerys reference that you've seen on House of
the Dragon so far the funny thing is is that even
Robert Baratheon on Game of Thrones is also like
the great great grandson of rhaenyra many many
times removed so like Robert Baratheon Daenerys
episode 1 they opened the episode after a quick
flashback to the great Council of 101 AC with
a direct mention of Daenerys Targaryen like they
literally write her name at the beginning of the
episode before she's born and before the Mad King
her father aerys II is killed by Jaime Lannister
during Robert's Rebellion burn them all indeed
even though at the end of the episode and during
the episode 2 trailer that I just did a video for
I'll put a link at the end of this and down in
the description below so you can re-watch that
you hear raniera reading aegon the conqueror's
prophecy which he calls A Song of Ice and Fire
but during his Song of Ice and Fire document that
aegon the Conqueror wrote he also literally wrote
down and referenced the prince who was promised
which is all also meant to be a reference to
Jon Snow in addition to Daenerys from my blood
come the prince that was promised and his will
be the song ice and fire like this Dragon dream
that he had is a reference to both Jon Snow and
Daenerys because Jon Snow is literally the son
of Ice and Fire but together Jon Snow Engineers
like when they come together they become the Song
of Ice and Fire because Starks and targaryens so
really the original Dragon dream the aegon the
Conqueror had was supposed to be about two people
instead of the document that he wrote he thought
that it was just about one Heir like my future
air will stop this coming threat talking about
the long night the white walkers George R Martin
also writes that prophecy is a big deal in Game of
Thrones but most people misinterpret prophecies
so like aegon the Conqueror just misinterpreted
his Dragon dream of the long night a little bit oh
it's meant to be two people one of the other big
Easter eggs too is when she's reading and learning
about the long night these Dragon dreams is meant
to be very similar to the visions that Daenerys
had like your next big Easter egg here one of her
Visions in the house of the undying was about the
long night she saw a lot of different things it
wasn't just the long night but her Dragon dream
so to speak of the long night was the vision
where she saw herself passing through the gate
a castle black past the wall and saw the thick
winter blizzard just obscuring everything like she
couldn't see anything past the wall of white and
that was just meant to be her seeing the coming of
the long night in the white walkers and be seeing
more of a connection to Daenerys Targaryen because
of a couple different things like they look alike
yes but both of them at an early age at least
started on the same path like both of them were
Highborn ladies typical even though Daenerys
was living in Exile at the time she was still
considered a very valuable political match because
of who her brother viserys III illyrio and as we
learned later consequently Varys who was helping
orchestrate the Targaryen restoration planned to
marry her to Khal Drogo to gain access to his army
that was the whole idea they wanted to retake the
Iron Throne so they needed an army to do that
ages that at the time that was happening when
they were making those plans viserys her brother
assumed that it would be him to take the Iron
Throne so R.I.P that didn't go very well for him
so you have a male relative of hers obviously her
brother in this case thinking that it's going to
be him this whole time I until it's not in House
of the Dragon episode 1 Rainier also kind of had
a version of that going on she was a Highborn lady
basically like the most eligible Bachelorette
in the kingdom and everyone even her at first
kind of assumed that she'd just be married off
to one of the other great houses for money or
for some political Alliance really good example
is Dorne so at this point in history when House
of the Dragon takes place dorne still hasn't
become part of the crown officially so like a
marriage to the martells was considered for her
early on as a way to bring them into the Seven
Kingdoms officially but then just like Daenerys
rhaenyra's circumstances changed dramatically
like on a dime her Uncle Daemon Targaryen had
long assumed that he was going to be the one to
take the Iron Throne as she did too Daemon gets
exiled Rainier becomes the heir in the same way
that Daenerys became the heir after viserys died
a very untimely death obviously the difference is
that Daemon is still very much alive also at the
beginning of the episode when they're introducing
renira's character for the first time huge Easter
egg for Daenerys they introduce her riding on her
Dragon syrax while playing a remix version of
Daenerys targaryen's theme music from Game of
Thrones now Daenerys had three dragons but she
thought of them as her children very literally
even though Rainier's relationship with syrax
isn't quite as close as daenerys's relationship
with her dragons because dinners really didn't
have any other targaryens that she knew of at
the time that were part of her family like
she thought that she was all alone but syrax
is also one of the things that raniera cares
about most in the world she thinks of syrax as
being like part of her family all the targaryens
think of their dragons individually as part of
their family but also for those of you asking
if Daenerys dragons drogon viserion and rhaegal
are descendants of rhaenyra's dragon or any of
the other dragons that we're seeing on the show
currently daenerys's dragon eggs as far as we know
were a wedding gift to her from illyrio who got
them from a shy in the Far East currently there's
no documents that explain where the dragon eggs
came from before that so someone could have stolen
them from one of the clutches of dragon eggs way
earlier in the timeline when the Targaryen family
was still around in a much bigger way but also you
have to remember the dragons also roam freely
around the world before the ancient valyrians
tamed them in the coastline on the Far Eastern
continent like over by a shy way way over here
is just pockmarked with all kinds of caves where
a bunch of ancient dragons are supposed to have
lived naturally so there's also the theory that
daenerys's dragon eggs could have come from one of
the clutches stolen over in this part of the world
we'll see if we find any more Easter eggs for that
in future episodes or other series later in the
timeline but for Daenerys and rainera both of
them early on during their rise people generally
didn't take either of them very seriously like the
wise Masters then the great Masters in Marine both
laughed at Daenerys until she sacked their city
with her Army in the same way that no one really
pays much attention to rhaenyra beyond the fact
that she's like a commodity as the world's most
powerful Bachelorette most favorable marriage
in the kingdom and the other real big reason
why they want to make that Daenerys connection
at the beginning of the series in general like
the entire series is because they want to make
a parallel for the path that rhaenyra could
eventually follow like the famous line when
a Targaryen is Born the gods flip a coin one
side greatness the other side Madness which way
is rhaenyra going to go like will she eventually
start making the same mistakes that Daenerys does
later in the timeline and for those of you asking
about the Targaryen Madness that didn't become a
thing that the kingdom started talking about
in a bigger way till later in their family's
history closer to the events of the main show like
a few Generations before the Mad King airs II by
that time there had been many many generations
of heavy inbreeding leading to a lot of genetic
issues in the quote about the gods flipping a
coin with a new Targaryen turning mad eventually
was usually chalked up to that but the other
component in their Madness in general is just
the sheer Hubris in their family after having so
many generations of Supremacy with their dragons
and that started long before raniera was born like
way earlier in their family's history after aegon
the Conqueror conquered the six kingdoms didn't
quite conquer dorm so you can't call it the Seven
Kingdoms at the time during episode 1 she and
her father viserys talk about how their power
their control over dragons is an illusion the
targaryens are no different than everyone else
there's also a reference to the eventual Targaryen
Madness that Daenerys is supposed to succumb to
like it's not just a genetic thing when Rainer is
talking about how targaryens think that their gods
basically or like the next best thing to actual
gods and they have this Grand Mission that they
have to undertake all the things that they do
are ordained by the gods for better or worse
like better in the case of their family being the
ones to stop the long night with their dragons as
she's reading about here from aegon the Conqueror
but bad in the fact that eventually Daenerys
succumbing to the hype so to speak like getting
high on her own Supply decides that it's their
Duty their responsibility to help everyone around
the world and they're going to liberate the rest
of the entire world no matter how many people they
have to kill to do it like ooh that doesn't sound
like it's going to be good Daenerys playing to
kill everyone with her kindness her benevolence
this first series House of the Dragon is meant to
cover the dance of the Dragons the Targaryen Civil
War as the showrunners talk about it the beginning
of the end of of their family things slowly going
spectacularly off the rails in the most spicy
way possible so Rainier is talking here to her
father about how a lot of people in their family
have slowly started to drink the same Kool-Aid
that Daenerys eventually drank getting high on
themselves so to speak like we have this Grand
responsibility but really deep down for a lot
of the people in their family it becomes more
of an ego thing and more about power so it'll be
interesting to see how the show portrays the true
events of what happened during the dance like
what did rhaenyra actually wind up doing and
how similar was she to Daenerys like how similar
were their stories ultimately and why did rhaenyra
do a lot of the stuff that she'll eventually do
this was one of the huge differences in the way
they plotted out the house of the Dragon Story
from the original Game of Thrones series because
towards the later seasons of Game of Thrones we
kind of only got the speed run version of a lot
of characters plots we really didn't get a lot of
context for why Daenerys started to go mad it was
like the cliff notes version and the people the
actors the show after the fact explaining why
things were happening a certain way so that's
why they have a much slower burn plan for House
of the Dragon so that you just understand why all
the characters are doing what they're doing like
where they're coming from when things really
go off the rails and even though this video is
mostly meant to be about the parallels between
rhaenyra and daenerys. The Easter eggs they're
using on the show just based on the episode 2
trailer it seems like we're also going to get a
lot of Jon Snow references eventually too I think
they do want to have a lot of connections between
what's happening here and provide more context for
things that are happening later in the timeline
during the events of Game of Thrones like no
no this is why this was really happening this
is why aegon the Conqueror really conquered the
Seven Kingdoms but if you spotted any other big
Daenerys Targaryen references and Easter eggs in
the episode just write them below in the comments
my Full House of the Dragon episode 2 video will
post Sunday after they release it congratulations
stanskrilla you're the giveaway winner from my
last big house of the dragon video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can get your
contact details everyone click here for my house
of the Dragon episode 2 trailer video and click
here for my Full House of the Dragon episode 1
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!